the two things that get me the most
excited
in this world well other than my
children are design
and food and we teamed up with sam's
club to show you how
to combine them here to show us how to
create a
beautiful dessert table for the holidays
is design
guru and someone i've loved for so long
carson cresley
oh my gosh hi
where do we begin carson every great
table starts with a great base
so textiles protect your table
they warm it up they kind of set the
mood so i just did
this is craft store burlap and it just
gives it a really nice texture
i wanted to make this holiday table
neutral um for a couple reasons it's
kind of non-denominational it can be a
hanukkah table it can be a kwanzaa table
a christmas table whatever
and then we glamorized it with um
some gold accents so i had a lot of
backyard greenery to add that extra
layer of wow
and you can literally go out into your
backyard
pick some branches off of a bush and
spray paint them
so easy breezy inexpensive we're trying
to keep it you know cost effective as
well oh this is a great tip too
i don't normally do flowers on my
holiday tables because
they're actually kind of expensive i
like to do just natural things so in the
summer i'll do
vegetables for holiday we just sugared
these
pears oh yeah but um they look really
festive and beautiful and sparkly
but you can put them in your kid's
lunchbox the next day or you can turn
them into a salad or do something else
with them so you're not
wasting it you're not spending money on
something that you can't actually eat
and then the last thing is to create
kind of a landscape on your table
so you want different heights so i just
took these cake stands and everybody has
these if not you can get them
almost anywhere just to kind of create
those different peaks and valleys
these are cake stands we just put these
wooden rounds on
which are really fun they look very
holiday you can get them at a craft
store
so it just keeps it really visually
interesting and even these containers
like these hurricanes
we just took some double stick tape and
some gold sparkly ribbon and glued it
onto the hurricane so
you just really want to make it festive
and fun it doesn't have to be perfect
it doesn't have to be expensive it
should just look
kind of over the top and festive i
love this and the thing that is my
biggest takeaway from everything you
just said
is the different heights i agree you've
set us all up for such
better success with the different height
aspects
yeah i just i just think it keeps it
interesting and also
um one thing i didn't talk about i do
have candles and i like to use these
battery operated ones i know they're not
the most romantic but they're much safer
and they're not scented you want to be
really careful if you're going to
do a beautiful food display you want to
make sure you don't have a scented
candle burning that's going to
take away from the aroma of all these
delicious
chocolatey beautiful holiday concoctions
i
actually think these might be the best
versions of a fake candle i've ever seen
and it's because it's moving like a
flame does that's what doesn't work
about fake candles
is that no fluidity the way that fire
moves
this is the best one i've ever seen
carson
these are fun and we wrap them in the
um birch paper so they look even more
um holiday and they go with our kind of
neutral
woodland kind of natural tablescape but
fun fact carson okay first of all i'm
gonna get this
thing off of here if it's the last thing
i do god
darn it all right hold on do it you can
do it god i oh i'm gonna do it
just all right here we go dick get get
hit
thank you carson here's the fun fact
about
this sam's club cheesecake is my
favorite dessert
in the world it's so good i'm having it
right now
there's something about it that's
totally different
it's like you know when someone gives
you a hug
and it's sort of like lamp and kind of
half-hearted
the worst and then someone gives you a
hug
and they just like take you in their
arms and you feel like you're
just enveloped and held so beautifully
that's how i feel like all other
cheesecakes out there are
the not as great hug and this one is
like the strong i've got you the kind
you just go
ugh and you slump into that's this
cheesecake for me
one thing i didn't talk about that's
really important because
the holidays are going to look different
this year we're doing smaller
groups probably just our families or our
households we still want to make things
really individual so
you might have little shot glasses or
little glass containers
i tried to put everything um in
individual servings it's just a little
bit more health savvy
now for for this world that we live in
well all of these desserts
are available at sam's club and what
makes them so perfect for
this table carson well what i loved
about shopping for these desserts at
sam's club was a couple of things i love
that a lot of them are individually um
packaged so it's easy to keep it kind of
safe and friendly and and
um individually servable i also like
that they have a huge
array you want to have kind of an
extravaganza of holiday desserts
and because they're an exceptional value
you can kind of do something really over
the top
and not spend a lot of money i agree
um i want to thank you so much for
joining us carson i really have waited
a long time to collaborate with you and
please let's
have this be the first of many and guess
what bffs to help make your holiday
extra special this year
sam's club is giving the studio audience
a year-long membership for
free plus a hundred dollar gift card to
get it started
thank you vfs thank you i hope you enjoy
that
[Music]
you